So I think we're now ready to tackle natural daytime light and scene.
So let's take a look at the things that we're going to have to have required versus some
of the things that are optional to get a good setup for natural lighting.
And the elements that you're going to need are a light source for the sun.
So generally, this is going to be a directional light.
An atmosphere will be linked to the sun and adapt to its position.
A post-processing volume, which will allow us to tweak part of the lighting settings,
as well as other rendering aspects like exposure and bloom and things like that.
And then optionally, we can add a skylight that will contribute to the global illumination,
which I actually think is a really nice touch on your scene.
So we'll be adding one of those to our scenes.
A sky dome for background visuals if you need them.
Some volumetric clouds.
And if you need to, because you're using a static lighting solution, you will need
a light mass importance volume.
So again, we're not going to use this since we're going to be using Lumen, which is all
real time.
But if you are using a static solution, understand that you will need a light mass importance
volume to get the most out of the scene.
Now one other thing I want to touch on before we jump into the engine is that different
templates are made for different needs.
So if you're starting your project and you're in the AAC industry, make sure you do go to
the AAC tab and start your project from there because it will have some more advanced lighting
setups than say some of the game systems or templates that we have.
So yeah, not all templates are created equals and the levels within them use different setups
depending on the level that you start using.
So you have like the basic level, which uses a legacy daylight setup, the time of day,
which uses a newer approach, and then empty levels in case you want to start things from
scratch.
Now in our case, we're going to start things from scratch.
So let's go ahead and pop into the engine.
And essentially, we're going to recreate this.
So I've loaded up the Corbero Day map.
If you want to access that, all you have to do is go to levels and then open up Corbero
Day.
And you see we have a nice little setup that we're going to delete and recreate.
So I'm going to go ahead and delete every single one of these actors that contribute
to the lighting.
There we go.
We are lightless.
Let's go ahead and start looking at how we can add all the things that we need.
So I'm going to go to the place actors tab here.
And first and foremost, we're going to need sun direction or sunlight.
Let's go ahead and drag a directional light.
I'm going to rotate it to make this a little bit more interesting, like so.
There we go.
We have a directional light.
That's a good start.
Now you'll notice that by default, Lumen is doing a lot of stuff already calculating
our global illumination, indirect bounce lighting, all of that good stuff out of the box from
Unreal.
Now, the next thing I'm going to need is an atmosphere.
So I'm going to go ahead and add an atmosphere since you can see the backdrop is very dark.
So we add an atmosphere here.
And you might notice it tells you, hey, you need to rebuild lighting.
And that's because I haven't changed this light here to moveable.
So I'm going to go ahead and do that.
But also I'm just going to refresh this by just going inside the scenario and moveable
just so that it actually understands that the directional light is actually moveable.
It's just a quick refresh.
The next thing I'm going to do, I'm just going to bring that up there.
The next thing I'm going to add is an exponential high fog.
So let's go ahead and search for high fog.
There we go.
Got it there.
The next thing I'm going to add is a skylight.
Once again, I'm going to set that to moveable.
That's what I'll leave at the bottom, actually.
And last but not least, I think I'm going to add some volumetric clouds to get some
nice clouds looking here.
And there we go.
We have our entire setup that we had before.
And it's just incredibly easy.
Out of the box Unreal Engine handles all of this for us.
So one thing to note is that, as you can see, I had to manually drag all of these out.
Now there's an easier way to actually build all of this.
So we're going to go ahead and delete everything once again and use the environment light mixer.
So it's a really nice little system that allows you to create everything that you need for
a natural lighting setup within one window.
So I'm going to go to window, environment light mixer.
And here I have essentially nothing yet because we have nothing that contributes to that global
lighting system.
So let's go ahead and start by creating a skylight, creating an atmospheric light.
We'll create a sky atmosphere, volumetric clouds, and a height of fog.
So we literally just created everything that we had before.
And you can see everything's kind of stacked up here, but you can see we've got everything
that we created earlier.
But one thing I am going to add is a little bit of rotation to this light once again,
just to get to the same place that we were.
So you can see with the environment light mixer really quickly without having to know
the names of all those things.
And Real already has a little setup for you.
Now what I really love about the environment light mixer is that in the past I would have
had to actually start clicking around these and changing the values individually to adjust
the scene to my taste.
Now what I love about the environment light mixer is that everything is here at a glance.
So I can change the intensity of the directional light if I want to.
I can change the color of the directional light.
All the properties that contribute to the lighting of this light can be edited within
the environment light mixer and can be seen at a glance with all the other things that
contribute to the overall lighting of the scene.
So this is something that I really love because I get to just not have to click around as
much and edit everything at a glance.
So really, really cool little system there with the environment light mixer.
Once again, we're going to delete because we're going to take a look at some of the
other setups that we have.
So let's go ahead and delete this.
And the next one I'm going to drag in is one of the ones that we talked about we were going
to take a look at, but we didn't look at earlier.
So this one's the Sun and Sky Blueprint.
So I'm going to go ahead and drag it in and you might be blinded by the strength of the
light.
And the reason for this is that if we look at the actual blueprint under the details
Oh, sorry, it's the direction that I'm looking for.
And the intensity is 75,000 lux.
It's trying to emulate the Sun essentially.
But the default exposure settings that we have here, we go to lit, you'll notice that
by default we had game settings.
And if you untick it, by default you have an EV100 of zero.
So I'm actually going to go ahead and bring this all the way up and I'm going to move
to about 12.
And now you'll be able to see that our lighting makes a little bit more sense and we can see
what we're doing.
Now you can actually change these values inside of the post process volume under exposure.
We'll take a look a bit more depth, a little bit more in depth later along the line.
I just want to show you how to actually use these tools right now.
So when it comes to the Sun and Sky, one thing that's really cool about it is that it's set
up as an actual geographical analog of the real world.
So you'll notice that we have a latitude and longitude here and also a time zone, date
and solar time.
So what's really nice about this is that if you say, for example, want to recreate the
lighting at a particular point on Earth, let's say Chicago, a certain latitude and longitude,
you could enter those values and the Blueprint is going to update and change everything about
the atmosphere, directional light and skylight that is inside of this Blueprint to match
the lighting conditions of that latitude and longitude at that day, at that time.
So it's a really, really nice system.
Let's say again, you live in Chicago and want to get the lighting right for the same thing
that's outside your house on the 21st of September, this Blueprint has you covered for that.
It's actually really, really nice to be able to have essentially a digital analog of the
lighting setup of a particular location on Earth.
And I guess really useful for the AEC industry.
Now, the last thing I wanted to look at is the HDRI backdrop.
Once again, I'm going to delete and you'll notice that when I drag the HDRI backdrop,
I can't see anything.
Remember, we edited the exposure to be much, much darker to compensate for that.
Since guys, I'm just going to click back to game settings and you'll see I've dragged
in my HDRI backdrop.
I'm just going to move it down a little bit so we don't get that crazy Z-fighting.
But you can see here that by default, I get the lighting contribution from this HDRI
image to my scene, which is really, really nice.
Now, one problem with this is that it does not come with a directional light setup.
So that's something that you have to do manually.
So if you bring in a directional light, you can rotate it, get essentially the right
light you need. I suggest you try to sort of follow the direction that the scene is
actually telling you to do.
So it'd probably be something more like this.
Assuming the sun's about that direction.
I can't actually see it on the scene, so I presume that's actually where it is.
So now we actually have a directional light.
Now, importantly, if you wanted to change the actual backdrop that you're using, you
can use your personal texture that you have yourself.
In our case, we're using this cube map.
If we go to the HDRI section here, we can drag in a different one to get different
results. Now, this is a nighttime setup, so it's essentially a moonlit scene, which
means that we would have to manually adjust it once again, our directional light to
match the values of the HDRI.
So in our case, we're just going to change the intensity to something like one, to
something more akin to moonlight, and maybe change the color.
We might even sample some of the colors of the scene here to get the correct look.
So this now feels like a moonlit environment using that information from the HDRI.
So they're the two sort of more out there blueprints in terms of lighting setups.
Let's go ahead and recreate that original lighting setup manually.
So let's go ahead and delete the HDRI backdrop.
And with the environment light mixer, we'll do it really quickly.
So create skylight, atmospheric light, sky atmosphere, volumetric fogs, volumetric
clouds, and high fog.
And I'm just going to quickly select my directional light here and rotate it till
we get a nice look. There we go.
Perfect. So the last thing I want to take a look at here is some settings to improve
your reflection information inside of your scene.
Now, by default, the setup that Lumen has might not give you the best reflections for
AAC work. So let's go ahead and take a look at this.
I'm going to bring a sphere in.
Bring it up.
And I'm going to go ahead and assign a material to it.
It's going to be a Chrome ball.
If you don't have access to this, it might be because you don't have access to engine
folders. In order to access the engine folders, all you have to do is go to the settings
here and make sure that show engine content is available.
Now, I have a Chrome ball here and you see the reflection that I'm seeing here.
It is reflecting what's behind me.
So that's a good start.
You can see the quality of the reflection isn't exactly amazing.
So if you have a good, powerful GPU that can handle hardware ray tracing, there's some
settings that you can actually change to make this much better.
So let's go ahead and take a look at those.
So I'm going to go to my project settings.
I'm going to make them a little bit smaller so we can see what's actually happening when
we change things.
But we're going to go to the rendering tab.
There we go.
I'll actually change the scene a little bit so we can see.
And I'm going to scroll down until I get to my glowing illumination system, which is going
to be set to lumen.
And then my reflections here, which are set to lumen.
So I'm going to go to the render tab.
And I'm going to go to the reflections here, which are set to lumen.
Now, you'll notice that under the lumen setup, we want to be using use hardware ray tracing
when available.
Let's go ahead and tick that.
And you'll notice that instantly increases the quality of our reflection quite drastically.
And there's another couple of things that we can do to gain a little bit of quality here.
First of all, is that the ray light in mode here is set to surface cache.
I actually want to hit light in for reflection so you can see a little bit of a better result
here. And next is the software ray tracing mode.
I'm actually going to change this to detailed tracing.
And once again, you might see a slight gain in the quality of the reflection.
So much nicer reflection than what we had by default.
That's something to keep in mind.
When using lumen for AUC.
Now, these settings that I've just changed here, some of them can actually be accessed directly
through the post-process volume.
So if I scroll down and find my reflection settings.
Same thing here, right?
You can change your reflection method, the quality of the reflections and the ray light in
mode, which is set by the project default, which is what we just set earlier.
But if you wanted to change it to surface cache or hit light in from the post-process volume,
you can do that from here.
OK, so I think that about does it for this natural lighting setup.
After this, we're going to look at some additional tools that will help us debug and visualize
our scene in different ways to help us kind of read what might be wrong or what might be
able to be enhanced. And then we'll take a look at some artificial lighting as well.
So stay tuned for that.